[Music]
we've come now to the quiz portion of
tonight's show the game is simple we're
gonna play two pieces of video for you
both from MSNBC over the weekend you
watch them and you tell us who's Dumber
the first comes from preacher without a
church al Sharpton Sharpton once worked
as James Brown's road manager so he knew
Aretha Franklin well as part of his
tribute to the deceased soul singer he
said this so in the words of my late
friend Aretha Franklin and show some
RESP ICT catch that watch the short
version again pay attention to the
spelling show some RESP ICT al Sharpton
doesn't have much of a formal education
he started preaching as part of a road
show with Mahalia Jackson during
elementary school he never learned to
spell even simple words he frequently
makes up verbs out of thin air if you've
watched his show you know he doesn't
read the teleprompter well and couldn't
if he held him at gunpoint now Michelle
Goldberg of the New York Times by
contrast is unwaveringly eloquent she's
got an advanced degree from one of our
country's most prestigious University
she's written a couple of books one
attacking Christianity the other
praising abortion that lots of critics
loved she writes for the most famous
newspaper in the world if you were in
journalism you've got a hundred on every
test they gave you you'd be Michelle
Goldberg she's the best our system
produces here's what she said on MSNBC
this is the most vocal president at
least in real time that we've had in
recent memory right he is the leader of
the free world I know he's not you're
not the leader of the free world but
sorry he's part of a block that includes
Vladimir Putin to tear teh founding
people up and murdering murdering them
without any you know process and we like
to think you can say that definitively
so who's dumber it's not really close is
it and it's not the guy who can't spell
respect he's not stupid that's what he's
been able to game our system for so long
but the other one Michelle Goldberg
isn't gaming our system she is our
system that's why her comments and
comments like hers are so fascinating a
ruling class loses control in the
presence of Trump it becomes clinically
hysterical what a normal person i
consider embarrassing or buffoonish they
find existentially threatening they
abandon reason and proportion and
decency they don't even make sense what
is that about well the short answer is
that Trump terrifies them these are
people whose main talents are glibness
and obedience and that's enough to
succeed in the globalized economy that's
what the system requires lemming-like
conformity and that's what they deliver
they're not very impressive on some
level they know they're not very
impressive and it worries them instead
of trying to become more impressive more
creative and useful they maintain their
rule by bullying even as they place
themselves outside the bounds of
criticism it's been a very good deal for
them and then two years ago when
seemingly out of nowhere Donald Trump
showed up half unhinged and started
saying all sorts of forbidden things
some of which were demonstrably true
this threatened to expose their
ill-gotten power and privilege and that
scared them they're afraid because they
know they're guilty they've watched the
country decline as they have ascended
just as the rest of us have watched they
know what they've done they understand
exactly how much they have to lose by
changing the way things are and that's
why they're yelling so loudly